Let's see what the Vandermonde
matrix looks like at
the complex roots of unity.
Each row corresponds to
the powers of one of the roots.
So for 1, the powers are all 1.
The powers of Omega are 1, then Omega,
then Omega square,
all the way up to Omega to the N- 1.
The next value is Omega to the second,
so we go
omega squared to the 0th power is 1, to
the first power, what that ends up being
is omega squared, and then we have omega
to the 4th, omega to the 6th, etc.
In general, the kj-th element is
omega with the k -1 x j- 1 power.
This matrix has some
very special properties.
For our purposes,
however, the key one can be
summarized with the following claim.
We'll let omega be a primitive
Nth root of unity.
This means that all of its powers,
0 through N-1 are unique.
Well, then, the Vandermonde matrix,
parameterized by omega as defined here,
times the one parameterized by omega
inverse is = N x the identity matrix.
For the proof, consider the kj-th
element of the product.
For this we're multiplying
the K throw of M of N of omega
with the J column of M or
N of omega inverse.
So we're taking corresponding
powers of omega to the K- 1,
and omega to the -J- 1.
Multiplying those together, and
then adding all of those up.
Gathering terms from the exponent,
this becomes the sum over L,
of omega to the K- J, x L power.
Now if K is equal to J,
then every turn here is 1.
And overall sum is N.
Otherwise, we recognize this
as a geometric series, and
rewrite it as this ratio here.
Note however, that omega,
to the J- Kth power is a root of unity.
And then raising that to the Nth power,
must necessarily be 1.
So, this numerator expression is 0.
The whole thing is 0.
And that then proves our claim.
This is terribly important.
Recall that evaluating a polynomial
at the roots of unity, correspond to
multiplying the coefficients by
this matrix here, and of omega.
And we use the fast foria
transform to do that.
Now we see that we can
multiply these values
by essentially the inverse
of this matrix.
Also using the fast forier transform and
this will allow us to recover
the coefficient's given values.
This is why it was so
key that the fas foria transform
work with any route of unity.